hi I'm master Gerson and I'm the lead
designer for c-sharp I want to welcome
you to Microsoft Connect and share with
you some of the major features that are
coming in to see gr8 the first of which
you can actually try out in their
preview that's come out at the time of
this event so I'm going to show as many
hours in the preview I'm going to show
you in visual studio kind of head over
there right now
and for the remainder we'll take a quick
tour in slides and they will show up in
later previews and of course in the
final product so the first thing I want
to talk about is null which has you know
cost many an exception and I'll
reference exception in production code
sometimes and which we really want to do
a better job in c-sharp helping you
avoid so if you look at the code here
just a quick run-through of the flow I'm
getting some subscribers I'm getting the
names of those subscribers through help
a method which in turn is getting the
name of each subscriber which in turn is
constructing a string based on the data
the strings that are inside of the of
the person class that that is in the
subscribers collection so let's just go
ahead and run this code and have some
fun seeing all these nice names being
printed out and whoops to came out but
now of course we have a null reference
exception the null reference exception
if we can scroll a little here turns out
that it is in that code producing the
string and of course it's the middle
name that turns out to be null in the
the third person I was trying to render
here and therefore indexing into it is
to no reference exception well wouldn't
it have been nice if I had known ahead
of time not when my customer sent in
this bug report so that's exactly what
noble reference types are about as a
feature essentially novel reference
types are about solving the problem of
finding out where null should be and
where they shouldn't be and tracking
where they will be and won't be so to
make that that concrete let's start out
by
actually enabling the nullable reference
types feature and i need to enable it i
can enable it for the whole project here
i'm just going to do it in source code
so you can turn it on and off and the
reason why it needs to be enabled unlike
all other c-sharp language features is
that it will give new warnings and
existing code and we don't want to do
that to you when you upgrade except when
you opt in to that so you can see that
when I type nullable enable here I got a
little green smudge here that's a
warning that showed up in my code
because I Nabal the new feature so let's
go and see what that warning is all
about it says that this constructor does
not initialize the none nullable
property middle name
well none nullable what does that mean
well it means that when you turn this
feature on forevermore in c-sharp we
consider your your reference types your
ordinary reference types to be none
nullable we will stop letting you put an
all into them so that seems a little
harsh maybe but it doesn't sure that you
won't get that no later so it might not
be such a bad choice so I'm not
initializing it maybe I could initialize
it with null instead and make that
warning go away and indeed this warning
goes away I'm now initializing it but I
get another warning saying you can't put
an all into this it's an unknowable
reference type well what if I want my
nulls there in the language for a reason
you can't just ban them and sure enough
you can't have nulls but now you have to
own up to it you have to express we're
expressing here in a public API yes we
will have nulls beware here might be
nulls okay so we've taken responsibility
and told the rest of the world that
nulls can be here and now on the
receiving end the line of code up here
that is trying to index into the middle
name now we get a warning here saying oh
this possible dereference of null
can you do about that well you can do
what you always did you can check for
null before you dereference so I can say
if peta middle name it's not equal to
know before i return that and you see
that the warning goes away so
essentially the compile is tracking
where it's tracking peated middle name
year and anything else inaudible and
tracking where might it actually be null
and you just checked and saw there
wasn't no so in this branch here can't
be no and that goes regardless of how
you check for null today compile is
doing its best to track that and remove
those warnings when it sees that you
have actually checked properly and
ensured there's no null in there so
another way that we could be doing this
is that we could actually we could do it
as a conditional ternary expression we
could return that question mark this
copy and paste put a colon so bear with
me as i reformat my code but you can see
now on the two branches of the
conditional one of them gets the warning
and one doesn't depending on whether the
compiler sees that it might be no Lynott
and of course on the one where it might
be no we'll just remove it from the
result and return a string that doesn't
make use of of the middle name that
isn't there okay so that's novel
reference types the next thing i want to
share is ace extremes so in reality here
so I'm I'm iterating over the
subscribers I'm kind of imagining this
is sort of a live thing like whenever
somebody subscribes I get the name as
part of a stream and then I get them as
part of a stream then I get the name of
that and I print that out so this
happens over time asynchronously we
we're lacking a notion of a syncs
streams in c-sharp today and and we're
doing something about that and
integrating that in certain language so
let's say that I get an async version of
subscribers and instead of being an
ienumerable now then i async enumerable
that's like an enumerable it can be
reached ish but in its
it's one that's a sink so you sometimes
have to wait the next element and of
course now I need to change get names to
take an is sink in numerable and now for
each won't work because you can't for
each over a sink Norma Bowles but you
can't wait for each over them so that's
a little bit of new syntax that lets you
await let you for each over asynchronous
streams of course I can only await if I
am inside of an async method but an
async method can't return an I know
mobile it has to return something async
but that async thing can be another a
sinner mobile so now you're getting an
asynchronous stream of the results here
and if you look up here now I have to
also a wait for each the result of this
call and I can only await if I'm in an
async method but I can make main methods
async now as of c-sharp seven two and so
now my code is back to working again and
if we try running it you can see that as
these names trickle in over time the you
know the results are produced and print
it out and that for each loop is just
sort of a waiting for every round with
some delay and there we go we've
iterated the list that's produced and
then the program terminates
so that's async streams the last feature
I want to show you directly in code it's
a tiny little one but we think it's
going to be very useful inside of my
fake service here that I've been using
all along I'm actually creating an array
of people and then give yielding that
bag out now
wouldn't it be nice if I could easily
specify a sub range as slice if you will
of that array and you can do that now
with with the range syntax so I can say
I only want to get from one to three out
of this array and actually the syntax
were saying well I want one from the
beginning and one from the end and then
I'm sort of slicing off the the
outermost elements so the hat there
means from end and that's the that's the
async or sorry
that's a ranges feature in c-sharp and
that's pretty much it for the preview so
let's go back to the slides and see some
of the features that will show up in
subsequent releases so we saw this code
here in the in the in the example before
where I'm choosing between whether the
middle name is null or not but actually
the first name or the last name should
probably also be able to be null it's
not always that people have first names
or last names or maybe they have the
names but they weren't recorded here or
they didn't want to give them or
whatever so we should expand this logic
to more like a switch over all the
different combinations and you can now
do that using what we call recursive
patterns so I'm switching over a tuple
of the three strings here and then in my
cases I can put a pattern that also
looks like a tuple we call this a tuple
pattern but inside of it it has other
patterns which are then used to match
against the elements
of the tuple so here I'm matching where
there are non null strings and here's
the case for matching when the middle
one is null of course we should also
think about when the last name is the
one that's null or you know when both a
null or actually when the first name is
null or you know there's actually eight
different cases here and so your switch
gets kind of clunky now and we've long
felt that switch was a little long in
the tooth in terms of being heavy
syntactically so we decided now's the
time to add switch expressions which is
sort of a spiffed up version of switches
that are an expression form
so here's that same code written with
with switch expressions so the switch
expression here is everything but the
return and the semicolon it has an
expression then the switch keyword after
that so it composes better with other
expressions and then a list of cases
that are just a pattern an arrow and an
expression for the result and I think it
kind of looks nice here that you can do
these one-liners you can do this tabular
sort of layout and really see you can
sort of visually check that we handle
all the cases here but beyond that
actually because an expression has to
produce a result the compiler will
actually check that you don't get to the
end with some of the possible values not
actually being handled so the compiler
will give you a warning if you're
missing some and if you if you ignore
that warning it'll generate code to
throw an exception an exception that
says well you ran out at the end of an S
which expression you can do that
so that's switch expressions tiny little
but very neat little syntactic sugar
feature if I'm already saying up here
that this array is an array of persons
why do I have to repeat the type every
time in general when I'm in a context
where the type is clear why do I have to
repeat myself say it's a big generic
type or something when I knew up the
object can't you just infer that
well now we can you don't have to
specify these guys you can just when
it's given from context that these
should be persons you can just write two
new expressions like this and then
finally default interface members are a
feature that helps make it easier to
evolve interfaces once you published an
interface you're already locked in
because if you add another member to it
your implementers will break but we're
now adding the ability to add members
with actually with a method body which
is a little unusual for interfaces but
it's going to be really useful because
now existing implementers like
console.log are down here they can get
that default implementation without
having to change and therefore you've
added that member without
breaking them of course new
implementations will likely provide
their own implementation so this is
mostly a feature just to make sure that
you are compatible that was everything
have a great connect thank you very much